why why does my body do that when I get
startled why does the hair stand up on
the back of my neck it's similar to how
a startled dog stores spikes in the back
of his neck to make them appear larger
your hair standing up is a reflex that
was used for intimidation by your hair
your ancestors why do I start twitching
sometimes the muscles around your eyes
are always working and just like when
your muscles shake during a hard workout
your eyelid spasms and fatigue
dehydration or stress why do I get
goosebumps when I'm cold goosebumps are
actually the basis of your hair
follicles pushing hair outward and
attempt to wrap your body like a warm
blanket why do I get the hiccups hiccups
happen when your diaphragm gets
irritated and disrupts the natural
rhythm of your breathing the hiccup
sound is your contracting diagram
sucking in air followed by the doors of
your vocal cords abruptly closing why is
your ringing in my ears sometimes your
ears act as microphones for the world
and when it sound is too intense you can
break down the connection between the
sensors in your ear and the
corresponding neurons in your brain
right the resulting lack of stimulus
causes your neurons to freak out and
stimulate themselves which is what I
register as the ringing